this week we've got penis puppy name
change and snail transplant I would say
we're gonna say snail trail I'm like
where did we get it like the sheets
underwear his dick troll mail trail all
over the place I didn't even know there
was a sexual thing I got a lot of pre
come to know pre come oh it is yeah oh
but that yellow girls get wet
guys get wet too yep for our first story
Facebook banned this photo there was
this photo of a newborn puppy that
Facebook banned because it was too crazy
look like if I know this photo it looked
like a dick yeah the breathe is a
Mexican hairless dog horas yeah
Charlie's twinkling joe liske Winkle oh
I like those ever since I was there I
like those ones oh that was a hairless
dog oh yeah yeah it's a Mexican native
to Mexico cool be gonna [ __ ] that so
yeah it looks like he's been in like a
radioactive back you know and they just
barely saved it
well they took a dog in that boiled it
and all the fur came off but it survived
somehow they have cats like that too
yeah they're there in the middle of like
the living and then that they're
bridging that gap yeah I mean give it
that so they look like they're more on
the dead side yeah that's why they were
the perfect dog for Coco you're going to
cook it but we're like Anakin's like
made it a good thing you know like
optimistic yeah you're [ __ ] not ugly
you're between dead and alive pretty
optimistic guy up there wait what that's
a good thing he said yeah that was
positive and optimistic what she said to
you yeah yet the way she called
coyote way this is the photo that was
banned I see this [ __ ] oh my god it does
look like a [ __ ] that is so funny
it looks like a big-ass dick
it looks like a big thumb up there that
[ __ ] as wide as [ __ ] dude
as a basketball player you go [ __ ] a
mountain yam - that lady has more
fingers than no should that trip me out
you know that looks like they got five
feet it does a little baby finger there
- cuz the little paw yes name is Dominic
he's from the Philippines and this is
the Dante the father oh is that his
tongue sticking out that's what they're
known for
oh yeah it is a dog's name what's a dog
hey Dante
hey Coco - yeah it's funny because we
saw Coco and Dante Bosco is there -
e-news like I'm named after a dog he's
actually named after infernal bookie
play yeah so then here this is Dominic
with the brand new he likes having that
dick on his cheek you got upset when
Facebook who notified him that they were
taking down his photos in an algorithm
they just like scandalous like a dick
wait why would you be upset that
Facebook took down a photo as a [ __ ]
photo because he probably thought it was
just the photo yeah but there's nothing
to be upset about it biggest taken down
just get a key did it he didn't see that
it looked like a penis and I was upset
because that was a brand new bit like
puppies but it's just a picture
it's a weird angle this it's like that
yeah any Laurel thing some people see a
puppy some people see a dead puppy oh
now I get it
it's supposed to be fun Mexican Nick do
you see Laurel to see Annie I feel yeah
any day you show me this picture and
said scientists have finally invented a
dildo that looks and feels like an
actual dick I'd be like no that looks
like that goes with that article that's
nice skin looks real it looks like dick
skin doesn't it yeah that's the hardest
thing when you're single you just want
some dick but you want to feel like a
dick and the
do not feel like dicks feels like
rubbers and you need that man wait if
they could just make a sand bag like
this this yeah and then if it could like
squirt actual like so open up your legs
starting at you she's like go like I
gotta show you what I need I need well
all women need out there I'm done
service dude this is actually a really
good idea
you should invent that but you have
those like they do you know they have
the female realistic dog
yeah the Melbourne yeah they do do they
have Louie yeah do you need the man wait
somewhere else thought yeah no do you
ever switch up the way they don't lay on
you like that you beat on your chest and
feel he's he's barely learning sex
alright forget him you're new at this I
mean a baby right away by accident that
looks like a [ __ ] potato dere god
this looks more like a puppy in my
opinion nothing a buff puppy it looks
like a human is there only one puppy I'm
not sure how many where we're in the
litter we should have helped to next to
his face like he says that this was the
only hairless one that was oh yeah so
hear those thoughts oh you can have
prairie dogs too apparently yeah yeah
that's crazy
well I'm not sure what the breed of the
mom is oh yeah I just find it weird like
with the things that people get upset
about you don't even like yeah what on
Facebook and I put a picture of I don't
know like my girlfriend right and they
goes it's in a property I'm like
whatever I'll put up another picture oh
you know what it was a litter of three I
missed that so I thought that the word
upset was kind of odd for me I love
puppies but Filipinos like to be
outraged about everything
oh that's right I think just people just
like to be outraged right now so if
you're a person that doesn't take
offense to things in normal day life
like you don't I don't think you'd be
offended but people think that every
they're clinging on to things that need
to be about them I'd be outraged if that
was the like a puppy picture and then my
Facebook account got [ __ ] terminated
because they thought it was a dick and
I'm like man
[ __ ] maybe I'm sure it's not
like he was fuming upset like oh my god
Facebook deleting my how do you know you
talked to him on the phone I mean it's
just the way they write but even though
word upsets really odd he's just more
like oh that's weird you know I mean
yeah but then he ends up saying like oh
now I find it really funny because now
people are telling me like yeah that was
the best laugh I've had in like all week
but before that he was just like what
the [ __ ] is this like I put a picture of
my dog and this is what happened I saw a
fat dick yeah well I think cuz he knows
what he's looking at yeah and it takes
another person with like a blank slate
to be like oh [ __ ] belts like that and
then you're like oh I could see that
that [ __ ] look like every flaccid dick I
feel like I'm looking for dicks
everything looks like a dick or a boob
or a vagina or butt or something like
everything dude oh you must love the
peach emoji then that's a butt yeah go
to Joshua Tree all those mountains look
like [ __ ] are dicks really well I've
never been there I'll show you guys a
couple pictures later yeah yeah I found
a rock that you guys can find in Joshua
Tree I call [ __ ] rock puts it wrong no
I always see a [ __ ] rock I'll show you
it's amazing alright for our next story
there was a Swedish mother named Joanna
thirty years old she hasn't Joanna
huh I think it's yo Anna don't make fun
of her you know that's how I say it in
Swedish land angel jung-jae check the
fighter yeah Johanna Johanna Johanna yah
yah this mother it was a big scare
she has a two-year-old child named Kevin
so she'd say that part yeah the me about
given yeah then Kevin
so she decided to get it his name
tattooed on her self but the tattoo
artist misspelled his name oh no how do
you mess misspelled Kevin and what did
he add it a F and it became fun it's got
to be big to make it to the news that's
obscene
he added an L where he'll be like Kelvin
helvis oh no that's what he heard so he
thought he was a temperature measurement
that's his arch-nemesis Klein you know
people with like their
names that are just a hair off like
let's say it's uh I'm not Christina I'm
Christine yeah it's their arch-nemesis I
am Diana yeah so this will pipe even
more he was like you might as well come
here call me a ho but I'll call me
Calvin
no now people are gonna be calling him
Calvin because this mother and your
husband decided to legally change his
name to kill and I was gonna hate
Kevin's know too much that I wonder if
he always just feels off for the rest of
his life he's like I just feel like I'm
I don't belong in this name yeah I feel
like we're gonna fight with this name I
don't identify with Kevin that's a
pretty cool way to just go by sight yeah
just change that word wait Louisville it
looks like Noora Noora Nova is it Yanni
Nova and Kelvin this will fall asleep
you know before they tattoo yeah they
show you put that blue ink B yeah and so
you see it any double check it yeah so
he might have just it must've just been
like I trust this come on this one I
didn't get that for this one I love the
mom or was that like on the back of the
ankle they don't report what body part
and I can't make out dude what if her
lover's name is Kelvin and that's how
she played it off plus I like
kid had to change his name cuz she was
like well I don't want my arm to be
wrong he's 2 years old he's not that
attached to it he's - but you know what
numerology has you're never tattoo or to
your life path and all this stuff if you
like look up numerology stuff so at my
Joe or Joseph in numerology just
whatever you're born with I don't know
like I'm Joseph but no one called me
that but my elementary school friends
you but it was what you're born with
yeah so weird - like sometimes you grow
up with that with a kid right and then
they have a name but they go to college
and they get a new identity yeah for
example knew this dude his name was Joe
Joseph I think we've called Joseph's
whole life right he comes back he'll
call me Jake I might know your Joseph
mm-hmm
your Joseph dude I'm not I'm not calling
you juniors all my emails I respond with
J cuz I'm lazy yeah J even sign it's
already automated I'm even lazy to add
the automation my I always bye Nikki my
family always called me Nikki my mom
named me Nicole for the nickname Nikki
only teachers at school would call me
Nicole and I was too scared to correct
them so then my classmates in elementary
called me Nicole even though my friends
in elementary called me Nikki yeah but
then your brush Sophia's is Nikki this
is Nicole oh no but she named me that
for the nickname I like Micky better we
gone bye Nikki yeah when someone calls
me Nicole I don't even like realize
they're saying my name like they have to
say it like a few times me too if
someone calls me Josie
sounds like so like sophisticated if
someone calls me yeah no one ever calls
me Giovanna yeah right that's the thing
call you [ __ ] and only the elementary
school people called me call me Nicole
cuz that me too
stood up for myself I was like I like
the name Nicky better nothin like wow
she's a pig that's so funny when you
finally muster up the cards are like hey
[ __ ] back sit down God used to be such a
great student right
you just came out of a coma pull the
plugs I'm alive
well this you Joe it sounds like an
explosion happen did you just came to
will came out from rubble you need to
enunciate your laughs more alright so
for our last story there has been
medical breakthrough because it is
sarcastically sarcastically because
that's my wording your energy didn't
match your hand firework the medical
breakthrough and I got cancer cures now
you know I don't want you guys to just
fully believe my own opinion opinion of
this story okay I always believed it -
whatever you say believe in you you
[ __ ] hate these [ __ ] no this is
actually pretty dumb okay
and scary so robots again [ __ ] no so
apparently these centuries demon and oh
ok go home did you know that semen is
packed with nutrients folks all right
comes the Fountain of Youth and it makes
your skin beautiful yo so facials just
cuz you said ok I know this is like a
really weird thought but you guys know
who loved making it afraid right so I
thought about this right so if you're
like in a dire [ __ ] situating situate
yes so if that's true it that it has
nutrients right you're on only for girls
only for girls the girls like so if but
if you're like there's a guy to grow
that right you're starving you have
found food in [ __ ] seven or eight
days but you know there's nutrition in
his ball sack yeah would you Jack the
dude up and it has come for nutrition
nah okay it doesn't taste like food
what doesn't like food hold on if that
was the case I'd be like alright Jack
yourself off let me know and I'm good to
take the news about starving them yeah
just put it in a [ __ ] bag I'll eat it
but doesn't mean yeah
put it to go back yeah what the [ __ ] I'm
off on that [ __ ] you pervert
no like you did not I say she suck it
off I'm saying he would have to do it
and then you'll hear no you want to jack
him off whatever if you do this bad boy
you don't you know you don't want the
cement to be contaminated by the air so
you want to sure like when you drink
water and you go like this it's going to
oxidize if you don't get your strength
you know it's like an apple you like
haven't you left it yeah like an apple
or an avocado out well you see what
happened don't want it to oxidize no no
no no I will say I would rather drink
semen than eat a bug there it is oh [ __ ]
yeah okay I think you're thinking about
Steve steamin the imagine his semen no
don't imagine me imagine if somebody I'm
making a friend is always a white guy
it's never make sense you'll never see a
white an Asian person on naked and
afraid
yeah cuz it's too real very do the tango
this is easy make it it afraid in
Vietnam yeah tell you anymore because
this conversation is a lot more fun but
I gotta tell you it's their breakthrough
how much a hand fire breakthrough
scientists were able to transfer memory
what exactly that's pretty crazy Gary I
don't believe it that's too much so
that's against God I don't like it like
like this like let's say my memory of me
riding a bike for the first time they go
what and they put it in Gio's brain and
Gio can go also that's how Bart rode his
bike the first time oh yeah let me tell
you what the signs what if you faked it
with you have a fake memory cuz I'd like
you know when you're masturbating you
have faked scenarios transfer like that
because it makes my brains think I'm
actually going through that then I could
show Stephen like like this like this
you see my you see my imagination he's
like wait
since the night but it was good because
he's like all of a sudden I want to [ __ ]
firefighters like this he was like I
don't have a six-pack I don't have a
bottle I can't I can't do that so they
did this at UCLA and they said that they
used these marine snails that look like
this
my snails they transfer memory is better
geo they always start with the more
simple organisms with the traits and the
functionality that they're trying to
test oh I thought I pictured the snails
sucking the memories how do you even
test when nothing has memory Oh a lot of
organisms have known we we teach them
how to get the food like mazes through
mazes and stuff like you plant food and
they have different paths and no okay
notice I didn't interrupt you so much
good job okay so what they did is that
they had these one snails that were
trained to like they were shocking them
oh they they were tracing like retract
from the shocking device and and then
they were able to use this RNA or ribbon
nook that's on it acid you know yeah
ribonucleic acid it's like DNA but it's
really yeah like so we have the oxy
ribonucleic acid and then I don't know
other organ and then organisms have just
dude that was like listening to a
crackhead trying to tell you about his
financial planner dude senior I sound
stupid but I know things yeah so they
got they grab that from the Train snails
and then they they insert it into the
snails I had no idea about the shock
wait wait wait how do they know these
snails didn't talk to each other
there was something kept them separate
how do they know that it's not like
whales where they're like and I can hear
it and we can't hear it no because
previous previously to injecting it
inject injecting the orange like what
trees talk to each other they do you
know we can't hear it that they did test
the the shocking thing or like the poker
and so like they retracted before it was
like 15 seconds or something like that
and then after they got the memory
injected it was 50 seconds which was the
same amount of time as the firt the
first set of snails so that's how they
proved that's a memory was transfer
that's tight you know what other ways
humans already get memory transfer is
like they watch a movie and they think
that [ __ ] really happen to them and they
go all the way that was a movie that's
not my memory how they that's ever for a
dream hmm
[Music]
[Music]